- We both have very young kids.
Yours are two and six, right?
- That's right.
- Okay. Are your kids musical?
- They are, yeah.
They are.
I think they're more talented
than I ever was at their ages.
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] You sound like a parent.
(Kelly laughs)
- They're, no, they're exposed to it
so much more than I was.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- They're so much more comfortable
than I was, you know? Yeah.
They're, they really, how
about yours? Are your-
- I, you know now that
you say that, I think
because they grow up around it, right?
So they don't know any different.
So they've always seen
me, mommy, on stage.
They've always come on stage
even when they were babies.
So like, I think that they don't,
it kind of shakes off the
nerves a bit for them.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Your voice is so magical.
I was listening to you
earlier. Oh, it's so good.
So what was like your
favorite song as a kid?
What's like, what'd you grow up-
- Oh, you know, I remember
the first grown up song,
I think we share this one.
The first, the first grown up song
that I really liked was
Greatest Love of All.
Whitney.
- Did you, did you put
it on repeat in your room
and just keep belting it out?
- I did, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah. That's me.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And my mom hated it,
like, it's paying off now,
but it was a lot of,
we lived in a very
small duplex. (laughing)
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I don't think my
neighbors liked it either,
but it's like, her songs were so fun,
especially that one
and the message, it makes you cry. Yeah.
- What a message. I, yeah,
I remember there's this,
there's this cassette tape
that I have from when I was a kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I had my own tape recorder in my room,
and I'm just doing that last, you know,
I'm just looping that the final chorus.
♪ Greatest love of all ♪
- No prodigy. No prodigy.
- And you, in your head,
you are Whitney Houston.
- [Leslie] Oh yeah!
- You were like, I am killing this.
Yes. Oh my God. And they
had to listen to it.
(Kelly laughing)
I love that.
Did you ever do the,
'cause we're the same,
around the same age,
did you ever do the, like play and record
to where you could record on your,
like, that was with my first demo.
I did like the, you could kind
of mess with the tape on it
and then you could
record yourself on your,
so I recorded over people.
I was like, I don't like
this anymore. (laughing)
- Oh yeah. I would do, I would do my own
background vocals, you know what I mean?
- Oh, I was not that cool.
- Oh yeah 'cause you could, like,
if you record it on this side,
then you put it on this side then record
- [Kelly] Oh, the double. Yes.
- Yeah. And then you'd
keep flipping, like,
- You could get the
double for a minute. Yeah.
That cost more.
I was like, yeah, that
was, that's really cool.
You were rich.
So wait.
(crowd laughing)